host yeah exactly and we're recording
great
and people are starting to come in
hi everyone i see the number trickling
up so we'll just give everyone a few
moments to come on in
and get situated before we really get
started
ask everyone a few moments hope
everyone's having a nice beginning to
their year
there's the first meetup we have of 2021
so it's you know good auspicious start
i'll wait a few months before i do the
announcements just to make sure we get
as many people in here as possible
so everyone could hear everything we
have a lot of good stuff
i love watching the number tick up
slowly but surely
all right seems to be there's a bit of
an inflection point in the numbers
all right so i'll slowly get started to
doing it
um we already have a first question um
if i could find the chat window oh
that's nice it works a little better now
um
pele is asking you know saying thank you
first and then saying we'll be available
yes uh the talk will be available in
fact all the talks are available
at nyhakr.org there's a presentations
page where we have both the slides
and we have the video available in fact
there's about 11 years worth of slides
up on that site
and no 12 almost eleven and a half years
let's call 11 half years of slides
and about six to seven years of videos
so there's actually a really great
resource
uh really great see pele you're new to
the group i'm glad you're here
it's uh that emily hackard is really a
really great resource
for um finding knowledge like literally
going back 11 years worth
of slides so we have a lot of stuff up
there
so the very first thing those of you
that have been coming in person you know
the first thing i like to always do
at the meetup is say who is hiring
of course that is difficult when we are
in this
zoom format so what we're going to do is
in the slack channel for those of you
who haven't joined you can go to
nyhakar.org
slack.html and you can join the ny
hacker slack
there is a channel job postings you can
go there
and post any job you'd like to hire
people for
being that i am on screen and i am
organizing i'm going to cheat a little
bit say hey i'm hiring
i am looking to hire two positions and
account executive to help us
service our customers and an events and
marketing coordinator
and the really cool thing about the
events and marketing coordinator not
only to help out land analytics market
ourselves
you get a work on the r conferences um
right now it's the new york r conference
the art government conference with
planned expansions when the pandemic
ends you get to work on that with me
so if you want to come work at my
company either doing sales or doing
events and marketing
uh go to lander landeranalytics.com
careers and you can find both job
postings so
come on mark we'll be hiring on we'll be
hiring shortly so if you want to apply
apply now
for today's uh talk but in general we
have this
slack team i guess they're called slack
teams and we have lots of different
channels up there we have our help we
have python help get help
there's stan help there's a coven 19
channel
there's an event channel for any events
in the community whether it's a meet up
a conference or
things outside the community that are
cool events there's a channel for that
um all sorts of different channels for
being involved in the community
specifically
for tonight there is a channel called
jan
27 meetup this used to be december 1
meetup before that was november
something meet up we just keep the same
one going because it's easier than
making everyone
rejoin the channel so go in there if you
want to chat
each other about what's going on in the
talk tonight jump in there and i say
tonight
i understand we have people come from
different parts of the world
in this 24-hour block of time that's
what you're going to be looking for in
there
so find that channel go in there since
we can't
have questions like we normally would in
person that's i think we're all aware by
now
zoom please ask your questions either in
the
chat here in zoom or in that slack
channel
again the slack channel is jan 27 meet
up
you ask the questions there i will
collate the questions
and at the end or in the middle there's
like a nice break point
i will ask daniel the question and he'll
answer them
unless he refuses to answer i don't see
why he would but you never know
but so please go into slack and ask your
channels or into the chat right here
i will collate them and make sure they
all get asked and
seen speaking of the conferences that i
mentioned when i
mentioned my job posting last month we
had the
r in government conference it used to be
the dcr conference but now it's our in
government
the videos are just being finished now
it takes a while to get the videos
up we have lots of speakers we have
really high quality editing
actually your videographer and producer
uh is used to be a producer for nfl
films
and perhaps more importantly for double
dare on nickelodeon
so we put a lot of really great care
into our videos he's just finishing them
up now in fact the only thing holding
them up is me reviewing them
i'm going to get them reviewed and
they'll be posted at rstats.ai
uh up there you'll see actually we have
six years worth of conference videos
it's a really great resource i hope
everyone has a chance to look at them
and we will we will be sending an email
to the whole group
as soon as we get those videos posted up
on our stats.iai
that will go faster as soon as we get
the events person in place intent i want
to thank
ecohealth alliance for providing the
zoom they've been providing the zoom
uh since april we started doing this
virtually
which i think is really fitting because
they've researched coronaviruses amongst
many other things
so it's nice they've been doing this so
thank you gnome and emma for
helping us out all these months um it's
been a great help uh
you providing this platform for us to
reach all the the audience
um it's really made a big difference in
letting us continue on with our i want
to say our mission but
these things these fun things we do to
help spread the knowledge of our
um of course you all know this there is
no bar afterwards because you know we're
in video land
what we did back i think in october
november we had a special meet up with
no speaker
just hanging out um and you know
socializing i didn't want to say
drinking cause like
some people drink alcohol some people
drink soda and water some people have
pizza some people had snacks
maybe we'll do that again next month in
addition to the meetup we'll do a
hangout
just so people that can you know get to
see each other that's one of the things
we love about this meetup
is everyone hanging out with each other
afterwards and getting to know each
other
so maybe we'll plan one of those i know
it was really popular we'll aim to do
that next month
um likewise we can't do our normal pizza
poll because we don't have all the same
pizza
in fact my pizza isn't even here yet i'm
going to show off the pizza but here's
an empty void of my pizza
it's coming i don't know when it is so i
can't show you the cheese lock
i can't show you the underside for the
uh for how it's
charred but it will be coming i think i
got a brooklyn pie again i'm really into
those lately
maybe it's a round pie um um my wife
becky ordered it so we'll see you know
what she ordered when he gets here
i hope everyone is enjoying whatever
you're eating hopefully pizza but if
it's another food i hope you're enjoying
that
that's a big part of this meet up
community you know how much i love
involving food
so i think that's everything we have to
go over remember
jobs you want to post a job doing a job
postings channel you want to apply for a
job at my company go to
landeranalytics.com
if you have questions go to the jan 27
meetup the
videos will be posted at nyhackguard.org
the videos for the conference will be at
rstats.ai
and i believe that is everything
um i see a bunch of people saying hi in
the meetup channel that's great
um i hope everyone in there gets to have
a good time
uh so lauren's saying we should do a
double blind pizza orderings and taste
things
normally we do a not blind at all pizza
ratings
in fact if you were to go to bitly slash
pizza pool
a lower case you will see like eight
years worth of pizza poll data
we've been collecting this for eight
years so much so that thomas levine even
made a painting
of bar charts of the pizza data that we
put up for auction at the conference
and the robinson fam siblings were very
gracious they wanted an auction and gave
it to me
so it's hanging in my office which i
haven't been to in a year
and i love that painting so um we do
collect data we love this data
with that i am very excited um you know
for years you can do neural networks at
r
for decades thanks to um brian ripley's
um i just sorry i had to drop yeah
someone said i should have made a pie
chart instead of a bar
chart actually it's funny you say that
um tidy tuesday that community
they use the pizza data for one of their
tidy tuesdays challenge
and people did a lot of faceted pie
charts so it's up there somewhere in
tidy tuesday people did the pie chart
exactly that so there you go
um so even though they'll do neural
networks in our
thanks to brian ripley for decades using
the internet package
but deep learning is a different beast a
few years ago we
the good folks at our studio came out
with keras and tensorflow
which opened up modern deep learning
into r but oh
you had to go through python so i've
been really excited to watch this
uh come through of torch which
goes straight to libs to the the is
either c or c plus plus i'll let our
speaker tell us that
i've been really excited for this
because i don't have to manage a python
installation for these projects
nothing wrong with python but i want one
language at a time to make my personal
life a little bit easier
so i'm super excited for this i've been
um chasing daniel for a few months to
get him to speak
i'm super glad he's here everyone please
give a virtual
warm applause to daniel who's going to
guide us through the torch package which
seems really really awesome
i have my own personal antidotes about
how
cool it is i did a 50 000 road distance
matrix in 0.03 seconds
on a cheap view of torch so thank you
daniel personally everyone welcome
daniel to come give a talk here
thanks very much jared thanks for
inviting and
i'm happy to be here and thanks everyone
that is
all watching uh i'm going to
share my my screen now so
[Music]
just a second and i think everyone
can see my screen now so
uh i'm going to talk about uh just as a
disclaimer before
starting like i i'm not a native
english speaker so sorry for my english
and
i hope you can understand everything i
i i'm saying and feel free to ask
questions
uh during during the talk
so i'm going to talk about the torch for
our project
today and my name is daniel i live in
sao paulo
brazil and i'm a software engineer at
our studio
and i work in the multiverse team we we
are a group of three
at the moment and we work on torch
tensorflow and sparkly are
mostly today i'm going to talk
about what is storage and
a little bit of the torch components
and how they they are tied
to each other and then i'll talk
how you can help us with torch and how
to contribute and next
uh some some of our future work or
something that we are planning to work
on in 2021
so what is storage
torch is just an art package with
two core features it has an array com
it has an array computation library uh
with strong gpu acceleration so
you can uh everything that you can do
in torch on your cpu you can mostly do
on a gpu and benefit of like
10 times speed improvements
usually and it also
has a deep neural networks library
video on this autograd system that i'll
talk
in in a few minutes
so why torch
torch for r is based on pi torch
and by torch if i
i don't know if everyone is familiar to
pytorch
so pytorch is a framework for deep
learning that
that has uh very rapidly
uh grown in popularity among
especially researchers um
and i'm not saying that
like still tensorflow is probably
the larger uh framework for deep
learning but
like if you see uh papers on archive
which is what this plot is showing like
you see that by torch has
grown a lot in in in implementations of
models and
so we believe that torch can help
the r community to accelerate
matching machine learning algorithms
because it has a very
convenient interface to implement all
all this array computation
so i i know that many
of you might compare
torch with tensorflow for our and i
will avoid this this question because i
work on both projects and
i think both are super great projects
so here uh i'll just say
like some facts that i think is is
good to know before so torch
is is mostly in early development
so we released the first version of
torch
three or four months ago while
tensorflow is much more mature in r
it has like i think the first release
was in 2017
so it has almost four years now
[Music]
uh torch torch uses leap torch
which is a this c plus plus library
behind by torch
while tensorflow uses the python
implementation via reticulate
what is the big difference and
torch in general has a
more lower level api than keras for
example so
if you are use it to keras you'll see
that
torch is more variables and more
lower level in a sense so
this is also important to know
um i'll just like
talk about the the torch for our
implementation so deep deep down there
is leap torch which is
this uh c plus plus library
that powers by torch so all the logic
for torch for tensors for the aldegrade
is implemented in leaptorch
and i there could be like a python box
here so python
is tied directly to leap torch
and here's the architecture for
the torch for our project so
[Music]
liptorch is a c plus plus library and
especially
on windows
it's only compilable with a
specific compiler called visual studio
and this compiler doesn't talk
very well with r so we have implemented
and we i mean it's it was mostly
uh javier luraski uh at our studio that
implemented this uh lantern layer
which we called lantern which is
basically a c
api to lip torch so
uh we can tie together lib torch
with r especially on
on windows and then we have
uh auto generated rcpp wrappers
that talks to this c api and
then next we have this torch
all this storage underscore something
functions
and the both these layers are auto
generated
code from like it's basically an r
script that
uh generates code that wraps all the c
functionality and on top of that
we have implemented in our old
some neural network models optimizers
and
data sets uh logics so one thing that i
think it's cool for of torch is that
all this is implemented in r and you can
easily look at the code let's see uh
what is
what does this optimizer is doing or
what is this
uh neural network model doing
so i'll talk more about all this
in a few minutes so just to
motivate uh
and i think like the lower level stuff
in torch i want to give an example of
something that
she's good to
and it's mostly hard to do
in i feel uh something a little bit more
complicated than that
so this is like the the lowest
uh the minimal example of something
practical that you can do with with
torch
so here i i have
this i'll simply load
torch and ggplot and then i i have this
function
f here that that just takes an input x
and uh squares it
and does minus x so this is
a parabola like like that
let's see if i can show you yeah
it's it's simply a parabola here
and think that
you want to use some algorithm
to find the minimum value
of this function so imagine that
you can you can you want to find the
minimum
the the y-axis and for that
you want to use uh some kind of gradient
descent outward
so uh one thing that
for to implement the gradient descent
algorithm
in r in base r or mostly like that
you would need to to to know how to
compute the derivatives
of this function and like i don't know
if if you have ever done some
uh the math class in the university and
i think this is probably one of the
first things that you learn
in a math class in the university is how
to compute the derivative of a function
and we can just say that the derivative
of
f of f relative to x
here is this is this other function here
okay so
and now like if i am implementing
gradient descent i'm going to
start with an x value
that it's minus two so i start uh
here in this curve and i went to uh
an inter in iterative algorithm that
will go down through this this parabola
and end up in the minimum value here so
our this learning height rate out of
i'll
not comment now and neither these
segments
to go here because it's it's just like
for practical
uh examples
and so i start my x value and then
i ran this for loop and what i'm doing
here
is like i just saved the starting value
and then i update x in the direction
of the derivative of f relative
related to x here and
multiply it by this learning rate if if
this learning rate value is too large
i'm saying like i believe very much
in this gradient for from for example
and i
i really want to go in that direction
but
usually we we don't believe too much
in this estimate because we are we are
doing this with samples and everything
so
we we usually use that as more hungry
for that
but anyways and then we can see like
the steps of this algorithm like this
and so we started at x minus 2 which
was giving us minus 6 in the
y axis and then we we went down
to here and then the next step of the
algorithm when
we went down one more step
and one more step and then we ended up
in the minimum of this function right
so each arrow here is the
is showing like the starting point and
the
end point here of this and the
end of each iteration of the output
and we see that in the end
we found x equals 0.4
that is x approximates the minimum of
of this function okay
and you might be wondering what what
does that
uh relate to torch and i'll we
we will get to that in the slides in a
few minutes
so i'm going to i'm going back to torch
now
okay so torch
has uh
these components and so torch is mostly
split
in these components it has sensors and
tensors
is really the main data structure in
torch everything in torch works with
tensors
and tensors are like the data here
or the parameters or everything that
uh that fits into this uh data structure
or tensors are like arrays in our
or our general
arrays okay then
torch has the array computation library
which
works with tensors so
all these these functions in this array
computation library
takes dancers and do something with them
like uh creating some like
taking the meaning of a tensor or doing
a convolution in a tense or
anything that you want the other
component of torch is autograd
and we will talk about that later but
autograd is responsible for computing
derivatives or gradients in an automated
way
then we have the oh sorry and then we
have the
the higher level uh
models in torch so we have the nn models
which i'm going to
and we have the just in time compiler
that i'll also talk about
so these are the main torch components
at the moment
so let's start with tensors dancers
uh are like a continuous array of memory
like a pointer to an array of memory
in your computer and
tensors have a few attributes that are
important so
they have a data type so a dancer can be
an integer tensor or a float sensor
a double tensor or anything that you
want
um sensors can have a device
and the device uh in torch for r is
like you want your tensor to be on the
gpu
or on the cpu or like if you have three
gpos
and in what gpu do you want to place
this sensor
so this is the device of a sensor
a tensor like is a continuous array of
memory so
it also has an attribute like its
dimensions
so a tensor can have uh
like any dimension that you want
and tensor has the denser
object in our has also also has a lot of
methods and i'll
talk about that later and another
important
attribute is required grade of of a
tensor
and this is related to outer grade and
i'll make it
more clear when when i talk about all
the great
dancers also have a layout but like
it starts to to become too much i'm not
going to talk about
layouts of tensors
so tensors can be
created from our objects and
for that he would use the torch tensor
function
so you just call torch tensor in a
in in our object in an atomic object and
you get a
torch tensor so currently we only
support
integer and doubles
and logicals so you can't convert
ours our character factors or
are complex vectors to torch tensors but
this can be implemented in the future
so yeah you get if you convert an
integer tensor you've got a long tensor
in charge
if you convert a
numeric matrix from r
you get a float answering torch
okay so this is like a
design decision uh that might be
important for some of you so
basically numeric uh values in our
are doubles but when we
convert from r to torch
we usually convert to float because this
is what's
mostly the mostly used data type in
deep learning because it's faster than
computing stuff in double precis
precision so uh
you you will get a float you should
convert
an r vector and and our numeric vector
to a tensor
and then like if you
[Music]
this is how you convert our objects to
tensors but you can also
create a torch sensors
directly from torch and we have many uh
initialization functions like for
example torch
range and this will initialize
rainbow numbers with normal distribution
and
what you put in the parameters is the
dimensions of the tensor that you want
to create
so here i'm creating a 2x2
matrix with standard normal distribution
and if i put a single number i'm
creating a
length 3 vector and rand
instead of rand n creates an uniform
just using a an uniform distribution
and we have many other functions like
that
uh tensors also support
indexing one important difference from
our indexing is that negative
indexing doesn't like remove elements
from from the object and it's
more like in python it it will take
elements from the end of the tensor
okay so suppose you have torch tensor
one two five here if you index with
one you will get the first elements and
if you do
x minus one you'll get the last element
of this tensor
so i i considered uh
using like mine to use the same
[Music]
logic as r but i think this
this is more useful like usually it's
hard to find the than the
last 10 elements in our or something you
have to write a bunch of
things inside the indexing so
this this helps a little bit for some
some stuff
and there is a whole article about
indexing
in this link um
so you can also uh do
interval selection with indexing and
uh look there there's one
uh there are a few of these uh
syntax synthetics sugar for
tensors like if you want if you have a
tensor with three dimensions and you
just want to index in the last dimension
for example you can
use the dot dot inside the indexing
operator here
and this means like take all
dimensions before this one so
it doesn't matter if the tensor has two
or three or
four dimensions it will always uh
use the the last dimension here
and you can also use uh by default we
drop dimensions when you select
a single dimension but you can just like
in our
add drop equals false to avoid dropping
that dimension
and you can also like add a new
dimension to the end with this
syntax sugar new axis so
this means like please add a new axis
in the end of this tensor so
this is just like
some nice features i guess and
[Music]
you can also subset assign tensors
and that's all about indexing right
and then um
we use the dollar operator to access
attributes of tensors so you can find
the shape
of a tensor with the with dollar shape
you can find it it's data type so
x dollar d type gives us
the data type and if you do x dollar
device you get
the device and x dollar requires red
gives the
this attribute okay so this is how you
access attributes of dancers
um and you use
the two function to modify uh
attributes of attack of a tensor too so
suppose i have an integer tensor here
that is like a
long tensor in r and and
and then we want to to convert it to
cast it
to a float sensor you can do x to
the type equals flow torch float and
then you get a float dancer
and if you want to change the device you
can also do
x dollar to device and then this
dispenser is copied
to to the cpu device for example
and this is the like
i i think most most of what i
have about tensors and then we have the
the array computation library
so torch has around 200 functions and
methods
to manipulate sensors it torch
is i mean by torch is mostly empire
is inspired by numpy so
everything that you can do in torch
in pythorg is mostly one to one with
numpy
and we we have the same functionality
here
so you can take the mean of a tensor you
can
sum tensors you can do convolutions
uh and many other things like take the
median
and all that and
one thing that is nice and is that if
your tensor
is in the cpu it will use the cpu back
end for the
computation if your sensor is
in the gpu it will use the gpu
back end and therefore it will
automatically use the cp the gpu
acceleration
and there's
one thing that is important to note is
that there is some duplicated
functionality
like there is a lot of stuff that you
can do with torch functions and also do
with
methods of tensors so for example these
are
equivalent of operations like torch mean
of x is equivalent to do x dollar mean
and call this method
right and
yeah you can see the full list of
functions in this link i
won't like open now like there are a few
like i i find useful and maybe
hard to find if ever i need to use this
so if you need to uh combine
uh like doing a deep plier bind rows
with dancers
you use this cat storage cat function
this will like pile up to two tensors
and you can also
split sensors with the unbind function
this might be useful somewhere i don't
know
um yeah so methods
are accessed with the dollar operator
operator just like the
the attributes of tensors and you call
x dollar mean to get the mean of the
tensor and
one thing that is important to note is
that x dollar
add with an underscore in the end
is something that works uh
in place so if you do every every method
that
ends with an underscore is an in-place
operator
is an in-place operation so that means
that
if you do this and note here that i'm
saving this to an
y uh variable here but when i call
x again it's modified so
this modifies x in place and there are
some
cases that it will be useful to modify
stuff in place right
and now i'll talk about autograds
so what is autograde autograd
is like i don't know
a model in torch that can automatically
compute exact uh derivative of tensor
operations
so any operation that you can do
with torch is
trackable by some by this autograd
system
and this means that you can compute the
derivative of
that and transformation after you you
did it
after you did it and
this is the main feature that allows us
to use
torch for deep learning because in deep
learning we are always doing
uh gradient descent or some kind of
gradient descent
and you will eventually need to compute
derivatives of complex operations
and then you will need
an autographed system for that otherwise
you you will
you won't be able to finish your working
time because
you will be uh calculating derivatives
by hand
and it takes too long
um so here is an example of
autograd in action so suppose i have
this
x tensor here that that has the
two as a value and
i mark it with this required grad
equals through attribute and now i do
this computation with it
it's like x uh poetry
and i get a value here like i'll get
eight
here okay and now
i call x dollar backward
and what this function does is like it
will go
over all partitions that uh
all uh i mean it will go over all
tensors
that were used to compute why
at that have this required grad
equals true attribute and populate
this grad attribute and
this grad attribute is like the
derivative
of why y
[Music]
of y over x
so we we have this value
here so x squared is 12
because if you do the derivative
of x power 3 you have 3 times
x po 2 right
so this is the the idea here
so undergrad i i mean it's john carmack
that is
saying this here but i mean uh
other red is is nice because
you you don't have to implement all the
uh the derivative logic
just to test an idea and it it simply
just works when you
you do your computation and then you it
you just get the derivatives and that's
all you don't have
any more work for forgetting it so it's
it's a nice feature and now
what i what i like to show you is like
how we can write this example that
we hardcoded the derivative here
and we updated the weight and everything
using torch so
first of all we have like the same
parabola that
we want to to find the minimum
here
right and now
what i uh
i i left it left
this here but we won't use it use this
function now so
basically what we have here is like i'll
define this storage tensor
with the minus two value and i'll mark
it with the requires grad
equals true flag and then i have this
tensor this just
like this works just like any normal
tensor that requires
uh grads doesn't change anything for the
computation
and like this and now
i do y equals f
of x and i have y equals six
because it's two times x minus
uh i mean it's x o two minus x
so this gives us uh six
and then i i do this y backward
here and this doesn't return anything
but it modifies the x squared attribute
and when we do this we got -5
and this is exactly what the
value of the f
the x x
would be right so notice that
i didn't need to implement this function
by hand
or hardcode it because torch can compute
the
derivative this derivative automatically
okay and now we implement
uh the grid and design the auto
algorithm here
and we have like mostly the same
uh stuff that we had in our but with a
few
uh differences so first of all we need
to zero the grad
gradients because every time you call y
dollar backward it will sum with the
gradient
that was already there so if grad is
minus minus 5 at the moment and i call
y backward again then grad will be
minus 10 and if i call y dollar backward
again
it will be -15 and then
it goes like that so we do we don't want
uh we usually don't want that
so we zero the gradients and remember
that methods that end up with an
underscore
modify the tensor in place so this
this is important here so x
is now zero x
red is now zero
right and then we can like
call y and backward again
and this is like the same thing that we
were doing here
like x minus learning rates
times the f dx
but we use the in place operations in
torch for that
so first we we create a context that
disables gradients because we don't want
this operation to be tracked by any
autographed system here
and then we we do like subtract
learning rate times the x gradient
okay and
[Music]
this gives us the same
uh plot because we are doing
these steps here to to go to go find the
minimum
of this function
okay so i can see like this code
seems more complicated than the r code
at the moment
but imagine that that this function
uh could be something much more
complicated
than that like and
and like if you add a simple convolution
here then it almost becomes
intractable to calculate this because
this grows absolutely
and there there's no easy way to compute
the derivatives for that so
uh this is the minimal example of
what outer grad does but of course like
if you know how to compute the
derivatives by hand it
and it's just one line of one single
line of code
then it's fine okay
and uh another thing about autograde is
that
it supports extensions and you can
uh for example suppose you have a
function
that is not composable of any of the
torch
computations that you can do and
or for example you have a function that
you can really speed up its
uh its uh derivative
computation if you knew that the
operations would be in a
specific order for example you can
implement
a new autograd function and
when you do this you implement a forward
method and a backward method and
this is like you implement uh
the the function and the fdx for example
so
this would be something like that and
and then you can use this function with
as
it were any other tensor operation torch
and with autograd and all that there's
uh specific dogs for that
i like to highlight this feature because
this is something that is only allowed
because
we have uh uh a deep
integration with this lib torch library
uh
zipless plus library otherwise it it
would be
almost impossible to do this kind of
stuff uh
directly in our
and if you want to learn more about
autograd
you should definitely read secrets
my colleague at our studio uh
the introducing auto grad blog post in
the r studio
ai blog and if you are interested in the
details
of the implementation of autograd
you should go to the white paper of
of the titor's
team explaining how they implemented
that
in python
okay so now uh
i'll go through the higher level
abstractions in torch and the first one
is the
neural network models so
uh in torch all models and layers
if you are uh if you have
ever used keras so both models and
layers
are what we call nn models
and a model is like
think of models and layers like
they are just functions that take
that that transform input data
but they have these parameters or these
weights that
are like the state of this this function
so this is the abstraction we are going
to use for models
but think about a model as a a function
it's basically a function that takes
input data
but this function
has a state that you want to keep
updating so
every step in in the out the gradient
descent for example
you update you update the state of the
model
and
[Music]
the nn model in torch makes it easy to
handle these functions
and the state of these functions so
in our one way you could
have functions with state is like
creating a
a function factory that returns a
function
and like since this function is created
in
in this environment it it will know
like it will find w and b
here because they are in in this uh
enclosing environment right
so this this would be one way to
implement an end mod
a model you know in pure
r without any like other abstractions
but then it's hard to access
this this environment and finding w
and b or any other states that that you
have here
so like when we
when we use an nn model we
do it in a slightly different way
so to create an nn model we use
this nn model function and we pass
two methods to it you need to implement
the initialize method
and the forward method so the initialize
method is where
you will create and
define mostly all the states
of your function so this this keeps
things
really separated so in initialize
you implement the state of your function
and
in the forward uh method you you
implement
what your function does with that state
and an input
and then inputs tensor on or an input
data
so this gives a uh
when you this nn model function call
gives you a mostly like a generator that
you can
use to initialize uh layers
so this for example is the
implementation of a simple
linear model in torch when where you
like define the w weights the weight
and the bias like and they are
initialize it here and the forward is
just like
the the matrix multiplication between
input and the weights and adding the is
and yeah sorry and
here we we have the exact
same thing as in r so this
acts just like a function and then you
can
call it in an input sensor but
uh nn models in torch
make makes it very easy to handle
this state so for example if you do
linear dollar parameters it will give us
it will give you a list of all
parameters in
in that model and if for example you
want to access any any specific
parameter
in the model you can do linear dollar w
and you will find this parameter and
comparatively
it would be hard to do this in
if you use it bazaar because
you will need to call find the
environment
of that function and list all the
answers here and
what answers there are parameters or i
don't know like
it would be hard to do this you know and
another thing that
is useful for you by use that you get
uh for free when using nn models
is that you can move all the parameters
of a model for example to the
gpu so if you do model dollar to
device equals cuda here for example you
you move all the tensors that that are
here to the gpu so this makes it easier
to handle
the state and move between devices uh
change the parameter the
the data type of these parameters and
all that if you want
and yeah one
one nice thing uh that is that
all uh layers that
exists in torch and we haven't
we don't have all the layers that also
exist in pie torch yet but
it's like i would say like 50
then so you
all the implementations of uh
of the layers in r are
directly implemented in in our code
so it's not c plus plus code or biking
code
so the the nice thing is that you can
easily
like investigate what is it's
really doing yeah and
and also you can like read the code and
make it uh like and use it as an example
to implement
other models that you might be
interested
in so this for example is the
the codes uh implementing the linear
model
in torch and it fits in us in a screen
like it's it's not like called from
other planets
it's like
you i'm sure everyone can understand
uh this code uh without
uh knowing details about storage
right
yeah models can also handle step models
so if you have like a few uh sub models
in a model then like things become
nicer because you can implement
you can reuse uh stuff so for example
here i'm
playing this is the implementation of a
multi-layer perceptron
in torch and it has like a linear layer
and then a reload and another linear
layer
and i just call that them in that other
order here
and if you call like mlp dollar
parameters here you'll see
all the parameters that are leaving
in in this model and not only and
not only the the parameters that are
implemented
in do i say this like
you will see all parameters including
those of the sub models
so this is uh a good way
you will we will get to that but it it's
it's how you handle the state of
of uh an nn model
uh there are also sequential models
which are basically
like you just implement the the
list you just pass the list of layers
that you want
and since it's a sequential model it
will know that
the forward method here would
uh call everything in the order that you
declared so just become like less
variables if you want
and for for every nn
uh so every function in torch that
starts with
nn underscore is like an nn model
and but there there are also functions
that is
that start with an n f underscore
and this is the functional api of uh
torch and this is basically like
lower level than this and
if you use the the functional api
you you are basically saying like
i don't need torch to manage states i'll
manage
states of this model somewhere else
i just want to call the same operation
that it's doing like the same forward
operation
so this is how it's implemented in torch
like i i just like you were
mainly going to use nn
underscore functions when you use
storage but
it's good to know because you will
always see
nnf functions there if you use some kind
of autocomplete or something like that
and we have almost complete uh
feature parity with pytorch on an
nnf underscore functions but
not on and then underscore
layers or modules
and then in torch we have
optimizers and optimizers are that
are torques abstraction for the defining
optimism steps
and the idea of an optimizer is
to encapsulate all the code that is
responsible for updating weights
or parameters in models and
optimizers are also implemented
in pure r code using torch
functions and you can like
see exactly uh how how it is implemented
without
like needing to go to c plus close code
and you can also implement new
optimizers without knowing c plus plus
and things like that
you just you you can follow an
implementation that
already exists and modify stuff that you
you find that might be better for your
problem
and yeah like the implementation of
uh stochastic gradient descent
is or great reading descent is more or
less
uh something like that you like i showed
in
in an example before so for each
parameter
you will subtract the gradient
times uh learning rate but it gets
tricky when
an optimizer has states like adam
or sgd with momentum and stuff like that
so it's good to have an abstraction for
that
and torch has this opt-in functions
opting under square functions that takes
a list of parameters
and other parameters that the the
optimizer might have
for example the sgd optimizer has the
learning rate parameter
and then like in your model you just
need to call
zero optim zero grad and optim step
and this will automatically like using
the std algorithm update all parameters
that might be
that are in this list so this makes it
much easier to to handle
uh like if your model has many
parameters you just do a single call to
opting dollar step and then everything
is done
every parameter is updated for sgd you
you can find in the code it will be like
something like that like a for loop for
each parameter
doing stuff like that but other
optimizers might have might have other
other ways to update
the parameters that are a little bit
different from that
and thanks to christoph joaquinak
uh we have like i think at the first
release of torch we had only
sgd and adam because they are like they
mostly use it
but christoph implemented like all these
optimizers in
[Music]
in torch so thanks to him
you can choose
in a large list of optimizers here and
there is an issue for that there there
are other optimizers and if you want to
contribute one
you can go to this link and find the
list
there and those that are missing
um there are also learning rate
schedulers but
i won't talk about that now
and but if you want to learn about
learning rate schedulers you might want
to read this
blog post by sigrid that is linked
here and she uses uh
learning rate schedulers to optimize
training
um next we have data sets
and i think this might be the
most complicated abstraction in
in torch because it's very different for
what we are used
to in in our and
but i think it's it's important to to
know that
but one thing that uh i
i would say is like all this is optional
in torch like
like you can implement everything like
that if you prefer you don't need to use
optimizers you don't need to use
models if you don't want to you can
implement your layers
in a different way if you want you don't
need to
use autograd if you want to implement
the
the derivatives by hand you can also
do that and
you don't need to use data sets too but
i think
using data sets is nice because it
provides some
uh some helpers for you to
uh train your models without needing to
to figure out how to how to make
it work how to load data correctly and
stuff like that
how to shuffle data how to anyway
so uh
if your data set the torch abstractions
the torch data set abstraction
it is mainly focused on
when your data set doesn't fit on rent
on on on your machine on on the
ram available in your machine so
basically like deep learning models
don't need your data to be online
all your data to be online at the same
time you just need a batch of them
because use
we use uh use it we use a mini batch
uh updates usually so you just need to
have a batch of memory
and the torch data set helps with
with that so when you implement a data
set in torch
you use the data set function and then
you implement the initialize methods the
dot get item
method and the dot length method
in the initialize function you can
basic you can do whatever you want here
but usually like it's a common pattern
to download data or to
get parameters to find the data on your
computer or stuff
like that so for example here i'm
passing
like paths to images which would be a
character vector
in r with a bunch of paths
and the labels for each one of these
paths
and then i save both of these values in
the self
object here and the self object can be
accessed
by any of these other methods that you
implement here
and so the dot get item method will take
an index parameter or i here
and we'll return the this observation
this is specific
objects observation so so for example
here like if i index by
by uh this index here
we will in the dot get item method will
read that image
in in this path and return a list of
the image and its label that it was
saved in this
this object labels here
so each time i call dot get item
i'll get uh a different
image but notice that i don't need to
have all the images
loaded on ran because dot get item
will read each image as it needs it
right and
then we have the dot length method that
just says
like how to compute uh the size of this
data set
or or how many observations did this
data set have
and yeah that's it
we initialize a data set by passing
the character vector of paths
and their labels and then like
this object can be can can be
indexed or can take you can also think
the length of this object if you want
if you index by one it will basically
call dot get item with one here if you
do
ds uh subset two it will
basically call the dot get item with two
gears so
that's all so
[Music]
data set initialize can do anything that
you want
uh it's you can prepare data
you can like create compute intermediate
intermediate files you can like do
anything that one downloads data
anything
[Music]
and the dot get item function can also
do anything that you want
so for image problems it's common
to use dot get item to read images from
disk
but you could like query stuff
from a database or from an rest api
i don't know you could like do some
kind of pre-processing there or like
do some kind of data augmentation like
in images it's common to rotate images
or
like uh do some kind of reversed
uh mirroring transformation or stuff
like that
and yeah that that's it
and since all data sets are
basically pure our code too you can find
a bunch of examples of
data sets that we already implemented
and
find like how do i do that and you can
just look at
our code and and see how it works
and now there there is the data loader
and data loaders are like our function
data loaders is another abstraction and
data loaders takes
data sets and they can iterate
iterate over this data set
and they can take uh and the main idea
of a data loader is to take batches
of of a data set so usually in deep
learning
that i mean the deep learning
you usually use uh
bad mini batch algorithms so you need to
load
a batch of data and the data set
abstraction is tailored to read one
observation with the dot get item method
and data loaders will basically read
like
a batch or call
dot get item for multiple indexes
and data loaders can shuffle
uh things and they are uh
an easy abstractions and they are
like uh they they try to solve this
problem of iterating over
data sets right and you use this
enumerate function like and
this will load one batch at a time
and this can shuffle stuff and
all that another
thing that that is useful of
data loaders is that they they can
load batches in parallel so
suppose you have uh you are reading an
image from disk
and i mean this this is a
cost costly operate operation and
sometimes this is the bottleneck of your
model like
loading the data to through and through
the model
and but you can like
have uh parallel
r sessions loading data and your model
uh processing them uh sequentially but
the data is loaded in parallel so
if if you add this known worker
argument to data loaders you can
basically like
reach read batches of data in parallel
so
it's it should be much faster and
it's not always uh faster because
there are a few things that you might
need to consider
so i just this is a benchmark
oh i think i won't comment that at
this time but like there are mainly
three
things that you need to before using
parallel data loaders
you need to to think about the number of
workers that you can have
this is usually related to how many
cars your machine has
or something like that
then you need to to think about the time
that it takes to run a dot get item
so if dot get i think is too is
very very fast then there is no sense to
use
uh parallel data loaders because
the overhead of using parallel stuff
will we won't won't compensate the time
that you you will gain by doing stuff in
parallel
and another thing to consider is the
size of
the returned tensor so if your things if
the sensor you are
loading in memory is very very big
then it might not be adequate
to use parallel data loaders because
basically batches are loaded
in uh different in different
r sections and you need to pass data
over these sessions and
uh passing data between sessions
is of course is a costly operation
and it doesn't if if you
if your tensor is if your tensors are
too
big then this uh
it won't compensate doing stuff in
parallel
so it's a
trade-off of these three things that you
need to consider
when using parallel data loaders but uh
i mean it mean maybe the easiest way to
find out is like uh running
uh the model the first time with many
workers
and see if it's faster than sequentially
and
that's all like just benchmark and see
if it's faster if
it's not faster just use sequential
that's all
and then i was going to do to
do a full example but i think i'm
really out of time like i i spent a lot
of
time talking so i'll i'll
skip that one and like leave it for you
[Music]
but i want to talk about some other
other
things so one thing that i
talked about in the beginning is that
cheat
it the just in time compiler for
for torch programs and the idea here
is that you you can take
this like this was released
in the last last release of torch
which was in the beginning of january i
guess
and uh
[Music]
suppose you have this storage program
here that
is just like a weight and a bias
uh tensor that you multiply and add
just like a linear model and compute
some value here okay
so this this is a a
pretty common function it's a simple
wire function that is using torch
operations
and one thing that you can use
that you can do now with torch is that
you can use this jits trace function and
you pass the function and then and an
example
input to to to that
that function so for example i'm passing
a
a matrix full of ones of this size
and then like this becomes a
function but this is no longer an r
function
this is a compiled function in a
something that we call torch script
so this trf n is a torch script
function now but it acts it
acts just like a commoner function so
you can
use it to uh to
compute values for and
and do whatever it would do before
but you can also find the graph of this
function
so this function was compiled by the
torch
just in time compile it using this
using this trace method and then
like what it did is
like it traces all torch operations that
happened when computing
an example input and it's
like transforming into this intermediate
representation
into this graph
and why i'm saying this why
this is important and the nice thing is
that you can
serialize this graph uh
like using this jit uh save function
and when you serialize it to a file
since this file is storage script it's
it's no longer an
art function with weights and all that
it's
like something that is
uh not aware of our at all
so when you serialize this to a file
this can be loaded
into uh python or into c
plus plus without any other art
dependency so the idea is that you can
write a torch code
here that does some kind of
transformation to a tensor
and export it to any other
library that can load torch script
okay it's and today i found out that
it's also possible to use the
torch serve
project to to serve these functions
in in the tracer functions
in like high performance environments
and
things like that so you build your your
model in
r and then you can export it
to a format that can be used by
anyone without knowing about r at all
of course there there's there are still
some drawbacks in
this approach so for example
uh we still don't support nn models
so you you can only trace
are functions at the moment and
you can always wrap a model in a
function and
do what you want so there's in this link
you can find like a hack
if you want to export an animal an end
model
but this will be implemented in in the
future
like it's not a lot of work and we were
implemented
probably still in q1
and another thing that
is tricky is like if your function
here
if your function here has a for looping
side
that depends on the dimensions of the
inputs tensor for example then
tracing won't work correctly because
if you because tracing we won't
we record the exact
operations that happened in the
in in the c plus plus code
and if this might be different for
different tensors that
then there is no way to tracing
to understand this from our code because
it doesn't know at all
what is r and all that so
it won't work if your function uh has
four loops inside it i mean it can
have four loops it can't have four loops
that depend on the
on the tensor input
dimensions
yeah and when we support tracing foreign
models this will also
give us like speed ups for
training so this will be very a
very nice feature that we will work in
the future
um yeah
and now uh i'm
just like some closing remarks i guess
so
how to contribute to torch development
and
i mean no matter what are your current
skills you can
contribute to torch development so you
don't need to be
uh c plus plus uh expert
or are or even our expert you
if you want to contribute to torch and
i'll give you some
ideas if you want to sometimes
help us in the development
we have a few open issues in our github
repository and if you want to like
try to fix them you can just
comment there and i'll help you as much
as i can
to to help you
figure out uh how to how to do it
if you think if you think uh there's
missing documentation for something and
or
something that you read on the
documentation and it it's not clear
please open an issue and say like this
is not clear in the documentation
i think it would be better this way
this helps a lot like torch is a large
project
and it's hard to document everything
like
at the beginning like we we just
released a torch
three three or four months ago so
if you find something that is not clear
please open
issues uh we we want to improve the docs
as much as possible and also
open issues if you find bugs or
something that you
are like if you think there is something
missing that is
would be nice to have in torch you can
open an issue
in our github repo if you
have questions about how how it would be
better
how what's the best way to do that in
torch you can also ask in our github
repo
and yeah if you are planning to add
new features to torch like there's
a contributor to torch
christoph that is started that started
implementing uh distributions for torch
so you can sample from
normal distribution or any other
distribution
with torch and if
it's a new feature and he's implemented
he's implementing
stuff and if you want to like you found
something that is available
in python and you want to implement in
our open an issue
and we can discuss and we can like
i can help you as much as i can
and another thing that you can do to
help
the torch ecosystem is to contribute
extensions to torch
so at the moment we have a few
extensions
we have torch vision that is like a
small
extension for that is tailored for
computer vision
tasks so you can like load pre
pre-trained uh models uh computer vision
pre-trained models and i don't know like
do some image transformations in torch
and this is implemented in torch vision
there's storage audio by atus
which is a colleague of mine and
he has implemented many
models related to audio tasks
in torch and it's really cool
it's a really cool project and if you
want to contribute
to pythorb to torch audio development
you can find the github github
repository here
the targets package which was like
subjects of the last
uh meetup i guess by will
landau uh implements uh already
implements uh serialization for torch
models so you can use target
with torch and it's really nice you can
use
all the features from targets
with torch with ease
we have uh submitted to crandis storage
datasets and torch datasets is a
collection
of ready to use uh data sets
for torch in the datas in the torch
dataset format
so you can easily train a model
for like the dogs and cats data set
that is already there and you don't need
to to implement
how to download data and how to like
organize the data set in folders and
directories
and anything like that so you can just
use this data set
we have also implemented this stepnet
package and
i think this is something uh
this is an idea that i like is like is
having
like packages that are
eased that are like torch is
much more lower level than like anything
that we usually do in our and
it's nice to have uh some higher level
package that
that use torch has a back end so you
you benefit of autograd and gpu
acceleration
but you back it back that in a
you know an api that is more convenient
for
uh for our users like
the tabnet package implements this
devnet
model in a tidy models interface
so you can use tabnet and never know
that you
are using torch but you get gpu
acceleration
and all that but you just need to know
the tidy models interface
and i think this is really nice and
we have also started the implementation
of lantern
and lantern is a tight models interface
for fitting
uh multi-layer perceptrons and linear
models
like logistic regression and
like anything like that and you
also wouldn't need to know anything
about torch
to use it you would only use storage as
a back end here
and yeah let let me know if you have any
idea or
like you want to talk and i'm happy to
to discuss and help with implementation
or anything
and yeah for future work
what i am thinking is like
it would be nice to have a better
internal probability with by torch
so torch tensors in r
share the same implementation as by
torch tensors and
it's also the same as it's the main same
memory model
as numpy so in theory it's possible to
make
like to convert uh dark torch tensors to
by torch tensors
with zero copies like they can point to
the same address in the
computer's memory so
it would be nice to be able to interrupt
between both
so you can like there's an
implementation of
some modeling python that you don't want
to translate to r
you could like pass the tensor to
to python and get back the values as
torch dancers with like
as if it were the same language
we also want to improve performance
uh of torch currently like torch is fast
if you have uh large data sets like
it will be much faster than uh
most of uh the things that you can do in
our without going to c plus plus
but there are some space true
optimizations
especially in the dispatcher which the
dispatcher is
like something that will take an r
function
and find what is the right c
c plus plus function to call and this
this is quite slow at the moment
we want to support jits tracing for nn
models and
this will also improve performance but
it will also allow you to export models
to
like uh to run inference or
train continue training python or
anything that you want
and also like in the same sense of
jeet we want to have like on nx
support so you can export torch models
to
the onan on nx formats that
is highly like at the moment i think
it's highly supported
and you can run on nx models in ios
devices
and like android devices or
windows like without any other
dependencies so
i think this is something that we want
to work on
in the future and if you want to learn
more
about torch you should go to the torch
for our
website uh that has many
and updated tutorials about art and
it also has a session with many links to
other
like tutorials the
the r studio ai blog has many
end-to-end examples about storage
so and you should
if you want to learn more about art you
should definitely
read the our studio ai blog
we have this the torchbook repository
which is a work in progress
book about deep learning with torch
and the package down website
has guides for other specific things
that you might
want to do with storage like
serialization indexing
and we will keep adding stuff as we find
uh missing things
in the documentation so
thank you very much thanks very much for
watching
and um yeah thanks very much
jared for inviting for for this talk
and i'm happy to discuss anything that
you really once
thank you very much daniel everyone give
a nice virtual round of applause
i see we have a lot of people typing so
let's get a few uh applause emojis going
and then we will start with the
questions i see a bunch of uh
questions uh thank you a lot of thank
yous for you a lot of thank yous
so give everyone a chance to uh get
those thank yous to you
um another question i'm just writing it
down so people hear um
clicking it's custom writing questions
all right
lots of lots of thank yous for you so
there you go very uh everyone's very
busy
all right great
and people hear that clicking that's my
computer making noises let me actually
take that out my microphone is right
near my speakers
all right i'm going to scroll to the
list of questions i have
sorry i think my connection is really
slow
lightly can you hear me
maybe not
all right i'll give you a second i think
my connection is really slow
so people are saying they can hear you
is there a lag yeah maybe it's better
now
there might be a lag and i'll do my best
to work around that lag as i ask you
these questions
all right so first stop okay um
there's a there's a bunch here so i'll
try to i'll try to move through quickly
um earlier in the first diagram you
talked about
r to lantern to torch so does that mean
we go from r to c to c plus plus
yeah yeah that's exactly it
i mean you are talking here
you we we
sorry the question was why we need to go
to
from r to c to c plus plus yeah why not
r to c
plus c plus plus why was why is lantern
in c instead of c plus plus
i can't hear you oh right um how about
now that come closer to my microphone
can you hear me
let me see if i have a different
microphone give me a second
nope let me try different microphone i
will um try
this one can you hear me any better now
sorry nope and folks um
can someone say if you could hear me if
it's because we could isolate this
if this is a issue on daniel's end
versus my end
okay um dana i'm not sure if you can see
the um
the chat they could hear both of us
probably i don't think you can hear me
um am i i i've
it's better now like i changed my wi-fi
settings so i think it might be better
now all right let me know if it drops
out again and we will try to uh
okay i'm not sure why yeah no no no
worries no worries at all
so the question was why are you going
from why isn't
the lantern api why is that not written
in c plus plus why is it
in c yeah the the main
issue here is like i can only talk with
things that are compiled with ninja w
which is a
port of gcc to windows but pytorch
because it uses cuda and all that can
only be compiled with
vs studio microsoft
visual studio compiler and i mean
when you when you try to cross to
make something that is compiled with gcc
to talk with visual studio compiler then
there are many issues because they
don't use the same memory representation
of objects
and stuff like that and you can there
there are many
psych folds all the time and especially
if you send
objects that are not c
compatible so this is why we built this
lantern c api so
uh so torch from r can talk with uh
with lib torch compiled with a different
compiler
and they can talk because it's a c api
and
even different compilers are using the
same memory model
so this is like i honestly i
i would never be able to do that it's
it's it was javier lourasski that
had all the knowledge to do this kind of
stuff
all right great that's so yeah i guess
i guess the c compiler can talk to via
visual studio compiled code better than
our can as the
yeah okay yeah and i guess they couldn't
recompile lib torch
from scratch for r you wanted to go with
the official compilation
yeah i mean we we could compile with
gcc but then we we would lose uh cuda
support which was not
like an option because the main point of
torch is being able to use gpus
thank you um someone asked is it zero
one indexed
i answered to them it was one index but
i assume that's correct
yeah it's one index set this is
something like
there is a transition period i i think
like
uh in terms of flow we started with zero
index and then
at some point we changed it to when
indexed and then we came back because it
was
uh so confusing to have uh stuff like
that
and in torch we decided to use wendy
indexes
for everything like if you do
if you subsets of dancers if you do
like the x's arguments for of
like many many torch functions have axis
arguments that will
like just just like the apply function
in r it will
apply in that axis and everything is one
time is indexed at one
but you might find some places that we
forgot uh we didn't find uh it was
one index set but i think at the moment
we probably found
uh most of them so and
at least we will you would uh have an
a-hole
uh like saying this should be
when indexed and do something
please call the guest yeah
great um yeah some of the gpus those are
still zero indexed i saw
yeah the gpus are zero indexes but this
was
by design because nvidia will always
show
stuff with uh zero indexes
so it would be like if you do nvidia
uh slash as in me you know like to find
the the your gpu names
and you would it would be totally
incompatible with torch and it would be
so hard to debug
stuff so yeah
that makes sense um and speaking of gpus
there's a question
um a how does this handle multiple gpus
but
b um if you want to if you do have
multiple gpus
do you have to specify when you do two
gpu or two cuda i think it was
do you have to say which gpu you want to
send it to or can you just say two gpu
and it will take care of it
and if you fit a model and you have
three gpus does it just figure it out
yeah at the moment we don't have support
for
like uh a higher level stuff
for gpus so if you want to compute
on gpu one you will need to move
everything
there and do some do the computation
there
and if you want to split stuff into
multiple gpus
you would also need to like uh
split your computation uh like that
there there's no
like uh how they say that like
i mean there's no uh
multi gpu support yeah there's no multi
gpu
at support at the moment but this is not
too hard
to implement and we might implement at
some
some point of of the year like there is
uh an nn data parallel in torch that
might that can uh distribute computation
between multiple gpus but we still don't
support that
like uh in a higher level at the moment
so because coincidentally i was on a
call the rapids ai team from nvidia
and one of their concerns about porting
it over to ours that multi-gpu support
is hard there's no built-in way to do
that
so you crack that then rapids can come
to r also
yeah i mean i i don't know
if this is an r constraint i guess
like it's it's just it shouldn't be an r
constraint at all like
all these should be managed by
by the the os that by like
the c plus plus library i mean or a c
library
down down stairs so i i don't see why
are uh why i should be blocking that i
see
mostly like this compiler stuff is the
hardest part
for for things for gpu stuff work on
especially on windows i think this is
the hardest stuff
and in light of that question there is a
there is a question about if you have a
very large data set
someone's using spark of multiple nodes
um and i guess
i think you sort of just answered it can
torch support distributed calculations
across multiple nodes
not cheap users like multiple nodes is
that a thing
yeah not at at the moment like
i mean you you wouldn't you you could do
some kind of uh
implementation like uh use your dot get
item to
call spark and or like
in your data set you can initialize uh
some
pool of uh connections to spark and then
like do some some kind of uh
i mean yeah you would need to
mostly implement all these logic to to
pass
best stuff to spark can you couldn't
spread the computations to the other
machines you're just spreading the data
yeah pulling it into one machine okay
yeah
i think yeah this is mostly
yeah at the moment you you would
definitely
need to to to do some
hacky stuff to distribute your model
between
multiple nodes and then go back and
merge them some way
like there's no like no high level api
for that at the moment does pytorch
support that on the python side or is
that like a torch limitation in general
i'm not i think it definitely has
some solutions for that like
but i i i honestly didn't uh study them
all i
i know they had an rpc uh framework for
doing
distribution computation
distribution between multiple machines
but i'm not a
i'm not uh totally into that like i i
haven't studied that at all
yeah and continuing on the same faster
question you talked about numb workers
um is i'm going to add to this question
that was asked um
so with num workers hey is that just
loaded is that
if that was in the middle of like a
neural network layer right doing a
neural network
does it actually do computations on both
data sets loaded simultaneously
you're computing the gradient
simultaneously and everything no
the the num workers are just for data
loaders so
basically you can like you parallelize
your
data uh loading so you you are
like and this is like
usually the data loading in deep
learning is the bottleneck
because you can have all your data in
ram so you need to load data
batch-wise but loading data
takes time like if you read an image
from this this can take time
and the idea of parallel data loaders is
like
not having this problem of uh of the
data loading bottleneck because you just
have like
10 patches preloaded and then your model
can't consume more than that in the
this time so you can have like your
model can be
constantly uh using the maximum of your
gpu without stopping
waiting for data to be loaded so this is
the main
idea so it's not doing a forward pass in
parallel she's not getting the data for
one forward pass all at once
yeah exactly so the actual question was
how does no markers work a gpu but i
think you just answered that
by saying it's just all about getting
into the gpu so it's not like you have
to worry about the course
yeah we we still like one thing that we
can
definitely improve in that is that like
the
the data loader is loads data in
parallel serializes
the output and loads into the main uh
our session
and we we do that very naively
like it's mostly an rds file and
and that is loaded to the main session
and i i think arrows i mean
i know that arrow supports uh c plus
plus
at least in the c plus plus library it
supports dancers
so we could like uh
if i i don't know if they are like
library already supports that but
it would be we could like instead of
serializing using an rds file we could
use arrow to to pass data between the
sessions
and that would speed up a lot the
parallel stuff
in in torch so maybe this could be used
even for distribution for like uh
distributing across other work other
computers
also because it's actually exactly how
rapids ai works
they use um arrow to get it from like
the
i guess in that case python memory into
the gpu memory so you do the same thing
yeah and if neil richardson is here he's
usually at the meetups he works on arrow
let us know neil
if you're not i'm going to mention you
on twitter so and you can't just point
me back to your
nyr um talk because you didn't talk
about that there so neil richardson
you're on notice to help out with this
yeah um because there actually was a
question
um here somebody i wrote it down where
did it go
about arrow right using the using error
to load in so i guess theoretically
i guess the question is about dot get
item that you could
use arrow because you're just reading
from disk but you want to do something
even better with arrow that we need
neil for yeah i i think arrow still
doesn't
for our at least i i checked it like
probably a month ago and
still didn't support dancers but i think
that
shouldn't be also like too much work to
to get it because it's already
implemented in the
c plus plus library and the protocols
are all
like uh i will tag him in twitter with
you as soon as this is over and like hey
hey at npr is his name uh danny i want
you to do this i'm gonna tag him
yeah uh continuing on with uh data
loaders
there's a question could you use data
loaders to do a cross validation type of
[Music]
thing
i i never used this
uh it's for for that kind of use case
i think it it would be better like to
to usually what we do in torch for
cross validation or for splitting data
is like
you have in your data set you have an
argument in the initialize function that
will
like split data into multiple uh
splits and then you can like say that
you want to use these splits
specifically and then
you just switch the data data set
parameter
and the data loaders the data logger
remain the same
you just switch the data a parameter in
the data set
when you initialize it so okay
there are if you go to torch data set
you can find a
few examples of where we have these kind
of
splits all right great
um while in the same section of the talk
i'm trying i'm trying my best to lump
the questions around the same topic
what do you mean by map data sets
um yes uh like at the moment
we only support uh map data sets and map
data sets is like
something that you can like
uh you have observations
and you know at the beginning you know
how many observations you will have
and all that and i think it's easier
when you
see the other possible data sets which
are like
iterable data sets so for example think
about
reinforcement learning data set
or so the data set is actually like an
experiment
and and it's like
the next observation depends on the the
observation that came before it
and it can like it can
it has variable length because an and
and reinforcement
learning experiments can end as soon as
like you lose it in a game or for
example something like that
so the idea is like you can have
a terrible data data sets that you you
don't know
how they are going to end or when and
this is this is their post of unmet data
set so
at the moment we only support the common
data sets that have like
a infinite number of observations that
you already
know how to uh how to
load and everything yeah can you
actually i'm sure the answer is yes but
can you like start if you have a model
fit and get more data
start off where the model was and then
iterate
and like i guess improve the fit like
fine-tuning the the weights
yeah theory like the model is completely
split up of the data so you can like
train
enough first training data save that
model and then
like reload it in a different
day and like have more data and
continue training it with new data
this works like the model is completely
uh splitted
of data it doesn't know anything about
the the data set that you
that you want so you could start
training like you've done 20 bucks you
could start doing the 21st epic later
yeah yeah that works just fine
um changing paths a little bit can you
index
tensors of logicals like you can in r
yeah
it is also supported like if you if you
do
like you want only the values that are
higher than zero in a tensor you can
just index
x uh x x
uh bigger than zero and you have the
the index with boolean
um if this one is from me
um does torch play nicely if there are
markdown caching because i know
keras doesn't really play nicely because
it's all c it's all pointers and
memories how does torch work with that
i haven't tried yet so
i think it doesn't work well i would say
okay i've i do think it's possible to
make it work well actually because
there there should be a way to like
uh use a hook or something like that
that
calls start save instead of save rds
into
uh that's that's something that doesn't
sound a lot a lot of work i can try to
figure out how to fix that i'm going to
say please do because i did try writing
hooks for keras a while ago
and it was a disaster so i'm hoping that
your hook will work a lot for torch work
a lot better than whatever i did
yeah i don't know like i i never tried
to do that so
i'm just it it doesn't sound but yeah
i'm not into like neater details or
like our markdown details so maybe this
is very hard i don't know
go knock on eway's door and ask him for
help yeah yeah virtually
all right good um you heard it here you
promised it within two weeks everyone
heard that all right
all right all right enough messaging for
that uh
lantern um do you need to set engine for
lantern models like you do for normal
parsnip models
uh yes actually lantern is like uh
an engine for linear models in
in torch in tidy models in parsnip
so you can like you initialize just like
you would
initialize a linear model or a logistic
regression
in in parsnip and then you use set
engine
lantern and then it will use lantern to
to
really use storage in the back end to
repeat
so you don't even need to use like if
you want to fill in your model store
linear reg it's not
something else yeah yeah it's it's just
a new
a new backend for it and you could do
like for linear models that you do
penalization and everything
what sorry penalization for a linear
model it could do um regularized
regression
yeah it's not implemented at the moment
but yeah
you would be you will be able to do this
kind of stuff yeah
same with the keras one um even though
charis can do it in in parsnip the k
it's like it's like if karis don't do
regularization same with stan
i've had many conversations with max
about that or many feature requests of
max
yeah i i think we we still didn't didn't
implement that but that that it's like
yeah it's also like
lantern is not uh cran ready yet so
it's just like like an experimental
project at the moment so
yeah but i think it should be
feasible to make it work like just like
with regularization and all right that'd
be that'd be really good
um there was a question it got answered
i'll put it out here
about object dollar method is that
something new but then gavin simpson
jumped in and said it's
from reference classes in r6 so
um yeah yeah
we they're they're i think one of the
main criticisms
criticisms for torches like we use
this object and it it's it's
like all new for for our uh
people like we we are not use it to
our seats at all like it's mostly like
uh backhand stuff
i guess like in shiny or i don't know
like
we use we use it but we don't see it
yeah
i i found that that it would be much
easier to implement storage using all
that because
otherwise like the
it would be too so much different
from by torch and it would be hard to
port
models and things like that so
i i honestly think that this is the
right approach for
torch but i i think there's definitely
space for a
slightly higher level uh
api for torch that is
still lower level but is more uh
ideomatic for r i mean like that doesn't
use
uh that doesn't show you uh reference
classes or
stuff like that but i i still don't i'm
i'm not sure
what should be that so i'm still waiting
uh
and see like how the project matches and
and then we can see what would be this
lower this
slightly higher level api for torch i
don't know
yeah i'm going to work i don't know if
the zoom is going to end in two minutes
if it does
i want to thank you now i'll keep i have
more questions to ask you from people
but if it does end abruptly in two
minutes thank you for this talk
okay thank you very much yeah um then
i'll keep asking questions as long as we
don't get cut off um
is there any benefit between the
function of object versus object dollar
method
is there any benefit one over the other
no they are mostly
the same like these resolve us to the
same zipless plus calculation
so there's no much difference at all all
right um then what happens if
the model like when you fit a model um
is too big to fit in gpu memory
does it crap out does it write to disk
what happens
yeah i mean if if you initialize your
model
and it doesn't fit on the gpu you will
see a
uh out of memory here and everything
will
like turn red and you won't be able to
to feed it so the model must fit on on
the
gpu but torch is very very flexible so
you could have like
some models if your model
your model has some models it it can
have like some models that live
in the cpu and other models living in
the gpu
and you can like uh just send data
between them
and of course you would lose some
performance but
you would be able to to feel it another
like
but usually the simpler strategy is like
uh i don't know like usually your model
fits
in memory and it's like the forward pass
that doesn't fit in memory
and like in this case you just
you you can use smaller batch sizes
and there's you in torch one thing that
you can do is
called like fertile batch sizes like
since the backward
accumulates gradients you can do
multiple passes without calling backward
and then you call backward after some
passes and this is like
a virtual batch size because you pass it
like
uh 10 batches of two that it's the
maximum that fits in memory but
it it ends up that you have the gradient
estimate for
for a batch of 20 because you did 20
20 passes and then you can like
me i mean virtualize your your batch
size i mean something like that that's
nifty
all right i did hear somewhere that um
jan lacoon was saying that
if gpus could handle the ideal batch
size is one but gpus are just more
efficient doing 32 or 64 or something
yeah yeah i i mean
there is i i think it depends a lot on
the problem
like in highly noisy data you
usually want a high larger data set
larger better because otherwise yeah but
i mean yeah yeah but i'm not gonna i'm
gonna i'm not gonna guess anything over
what he says or what you say i'll go for
this
yeah um all right let's see then here's
a question
is it likely that you could be
convenient to use a non-torch function
somewhere in the pipeline
and if so how would that affect the jit
if you're trying to use jit over
a pipeline has that non-torch function
in there
yeah if there is a non-charge function
it won't be trace it
and then like it won't work uh
correctly like it will
it it will when you invoke the tracer
function
it will ignore this computation that was
not using
a torch function and it will give you
wrong results okay but i think
we do check like the
the cheated uh function so
you don't get this wrong uh results uh
like when you call this
when you have this these things you you
you will
notice that you did something wrong it
won't be silent
i guess i i think we implemented that i
don't remember anymore and
i recall like you have overrode things
like if we do like
x matrix multiplication y like the r
like percent star percent
that's becomes torch mm right yeah
yeah we have most uh
i think we have most of the operators in
the art language
implemented for for torch so
it should it should work like if you do
uh the percent star like uh
it should call torch mmm and everything
should work fine
so likely if you have a non-torch
function if it's not from a package like
base r you'd probably be able to
like it's if it's arithmetically she'll
be able to do it in torch
yeah but i mean if you call uh a bazaar
function with a torch tensor you will
have
an error anyway like you if you have
a known torch function with a torch
tensor
you will have to do some kind of like
convert back to r
and back to tensor at some point apply
won't work or um
cross product run work yeah yeah
all right um
oh yeah so the training loop is written
in
like an r for loop is there any
advantage just writing a c plus plus
four loop or even a cuda for loop
i i don't think so like th the idea is
like
uh there's no problem in using for loops
in r
if if the computation that you do inside
uh the for loop is uh costly enough
that it the the for loop overhead
won't uh matter at all and this
this is usually the kind of computation
that we do in
in deep learning right like the model uh
apply the forward method of the model is
like a costly
computation computing the backward is
also costly so
uh the for loop overhead won't have
any noticeable shouldn't at least for
larger models but for smaller models it
can have some
uh some uh
most noticeable overhead but i don't
think it's worth it
to like implementing this
as a simplest plus loop at all
so then there's a similar question you
mentioned that optimizers are written in
r
do they execute on the gpu or what's
going on with those
yeah i mean the top the optimizers are
wrappers around storage storage
underscore functions
so if your data is on the gpu it will
run
stuff on the gpu if it's not on on gpu
it's
it it run on the cpu but
like the main computation there is like
the
is the the backward
and this is all c plus plus like when
you
when you do when you use an optimizer
like the r code is just updating the
weights
and doing like a subtraction
at some point it's all it's basically
all it's doing
and the hard thing is backward and this
is
this go through uh deep down c plus and
and when you do subtract that still
subtraction happening on the gpu
yeah yeah right we have a few questions
which are in the same
vein um what happens
without well if you don't use with no
grad
what happens if you don't do that does
it yeah
yeah if you do any kind of in-place
operations
in without disabling uh
grad the great degree the autograd
you will have an a-hole because by torch
doesn't
allow this uh i mean
it allows but you need to it it will
say that it's not a good uh good thing
so you see an a-hole
and you can disable the the every
influence but
you you can also make a mistake and do
a an operation that you would want not
to be tracked
and this would be a silent silent terror
and you would see like the gradients uh
not okay and
the model doesn't converge and these are
harder to find
but this is hard to do if you if you
use the the higher level abstractions
like optimizers
and nn models you it's hard to do this
kind of
mistake that you forget to uh
disable the edge or something like that
okay yeah you should
yeah you don't have to do it um along
this
there's a few gradient questions um what
will it look like if you don't zero the
gradient
are you is making are you growing a list
of vectors of gradients are you
literally adding the gradients together
like summing them up
yeah it literally just adds the gradient
like i can could show you like if i do
something like that and then i get x
squared
it's minus five and if i do again
without zeroing it it will be minus ten
like it just adds the gradients uh
and that's all it does like
great um i
this might be a syntax question
i'm not sure like is was there like an x
dollar grad underscore
or is that something made up uh
yeah i think there was something like
that right like
this is the way you zero the gradient
of x because that this
this is the only way to modify it
because you need
you need to do an in-place operation
because you don't have
really access to this gradient so this
is the only way to
write it zero zero eight yeah
um does j so i'm not doing completely in
order you know sort of also trying to
read what
people wrote uh does jit affect model
training like
can you jit a model and does that make
any difference
yeah in the future like if we
when we implement uh jits tracing for nn
models you will be able
like the the jit will optimize
uh your r code in theory your model
and you will be able to use the train
the
the cheat the cheated model to train and
it will affect mostly performance it
will be faster
because the jit is can like
optimize and combine some operations
that are done
and stuff like that
all right i'm hearing that my video feed
might be frozen
um can you see me daniel
no i can only uh hear you at the moment
i i yeah you are frozen
all right my video isn't as important as
yours so
i'm gonna let you keep talking here it
looks like my zooms froze
um yep i assume it's frozen so i'm gonna
keep speaking
okay okay so
um someone's asking can we get the
example live code
um can like the code you actually ran in
the console can you get that to us
somewhere
yeah i'll post on on on my twitter
like this the slides and uh a link to
the
the code uh i use it right
um then there
is a question about when your early
codes in example zero zero
you use as.numeric why did you have to
do as.numeric
oh i i think there's no like reason for
that
i think i just like the way i did these
examples like i wrote the torch one and
then i translated it to r and i think i
left it
by mistake like there's no difference
but of
doing just that yeah it's exactly the
same stuff
right then we have a few that are just
more comments that was pure awesomeness
the the everything was great you can't
wait to try it out um
someone else uh it's awesome the work
you've done they've been fitting complex
geospatial models
and they are excited to try this oh
experience trying this i'm going to
answer this one
um sigrid put out a blog post
specifically
specifically about doing a geospatial
model yeah
she's working on a blog post like
for uh predicting time series
with uh spatial dependencies
it i think it would it will be very nice
yeah
the blog post you put out already was
pretty cool so we're wait excited to see
more
yeah all right with yeah i mean everyone
that is watching like if you are doing
something with
dart and we want to discuss and like
please let me know and i think the best
way to
to share is on twitter or like github
issues and please share and i i'm happy
to help with
codes and all that so just let me know
um i know from personal experience i've
made a few github issues already and the
torch team is very uh responsive
um yeah i tried to answer it as fast as
possible
that is appreciated uh someone says is
torch available in our studio cloud
yeah you can install torch in our studio
cloud
like there's some
i mean it just works there there's
a period that it doesn't work it's like
when i submit to grant then the binaries
are not ready
in in the rstudio back package manager
and and like you can
you it doesn't work when installing in
our studio cloud because compilation
takes a lot of uh
rank but it it should just work on
on our studio cloud let me know if it
doesn't work i can
i can try to fix it great
um that covers just about everything so
i want to say
thank you very much daniel this is a
fantastic talk and thank you for doing
the work on torch but thank you for this
talk so everyone if we still give them
another virtual round of applause i
think that's very awesome thank you very
much
terence absolutely absolutely i saw
tommy is in here and every sauce
whenever tommy comes one of our talks
like oh damn i
need to rewrite my dissertation again i
hope tommy go rewrite your dissertation
again i hope you had a good time doing
that
for everyone else um remember the dc
videos the art got videos will be up on
our stats that ai soon this video will
be up on nyhakar.org
and we'll have the february meetup
announced pretty soon we have a few
months planned ahead
looking forward to seeing
thank you or say goodbye
bye good goodbye thank you very much
thank you bye
all right i think i'll just hang out
with you as everyone trickles out
uh thank you everybody for coming and
we'll see you goodbye everyone
and we'll kill this off
you